irina empieza el día recolectando agua
desde hace tres semanas las tuberías que
abastecía mykolaiv quedaron destruidas
la ciudad ha quedado sin abastecimiento
un tropiezo más en una larga lista de
dificultades que trae la guerra
y el problema más grande que tenemos es
nuestra seguridad porque tenemos
explosiones ataques con misiles y es muy
peligroso
fue la noche cerca de las nueve o diez
de la noche the news
más de 100 civiles han muerto en ataques
en el área urbana de nikolai
esta bomba cayó a pocos metros de su
casa
aún bajo las amenazas de los bombardeos
y los problemas que trae la guerra y lin
ha preferido quedarse en la ciudad
tiene 67 años y vivió la primera mitad
de su vida la unión soviética
y si me dicen hace un año y medio que
esta situación se daría en mi país me lo
hubiera creído
eso
fue tan inesperado tan horrible tener
una guerra en medio de europa
elena y su hija también repiten el
ritual de recolectar agua lo hacen
cuando las condiciones de seguridad se
los permiten después de trabajar
duramente por años ahora les preocupa su
supervivencia
no trabajo ahora la seguridad no lo
permite pero recibo salario pero es
mucho menor de lo que era y no es
suficiente para vivir
este café ha decido reabrir sus puertas
los empleados dicen que se las arreglan
para lidiar con problemas como la
escasez de agua
obviamente el salario es menor pero
vamos bien sin embargo muchos de mis
amigos perdieron el trabajo jóvenes como
lisa esperan que la línea de defensa
resistan mientras tanto ella pelea por
no dejar que la esperanza que destruida
por la guerra